dr crocker selected three unassembled  ikea stephon chairs as well as two  assembly manuals for experimentation  first one unassembled chair was placed  inside on fine without a manual the  output produced was an assembled chair  the piece is put together at random next  an unassembled chair was placed on the  same setting along with its assembly  manual the output produced was an  assembled chair with the front and back  legs swapped and damaged to the seat as  if someone had hit it with a hammer in  frustration for the final trial dr  crocker placed an unassembled chair a  manual and a note reading you can do it  inside on the setting very fine the  clockworks produced not a chair but a 60  centimeter wooden automaton with an  obsessive enthusiasm for assembling  furniture though was not especially good  at it